good morning everybody um my name is
Brin Haren uh welcome to the Joint order
and standards committee May first of all
just remind you of some domestic
arrangements please ensure that your
microphones are turned off when not in
use that you do not interrupt other
speakers that if you are attending the
Mee to speak and persistently interrupt
the meeting you may be asked to
leave please sure your mobile phones are
on silent or Switched Off additionally
we will be using EV EV voting for this
meeting on the modern gov
app I would like to remind everybody
present that this meeting will be
broadcast live to the internet and we'll
be capable of repeated viewing the whole
of the meeting will be filmed except
where there are confidential or exempt
items if you make a representation to
the meeting you will be de Deed by the
council to have consented to be
infiled by entering this meeting as a
speaker you were also consenting to
being recorded by the council and to
have the possible use of those images
and sound recordings for webcasting and
for other training
purposes the council members of the
public and the Press May record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the Press are not
lawfully excluded
now in attendance today from the offices
um we have Melissa rans director of
corporate resources Jan Robinson the
monitoring
officer Kum watman is not here we have
Mike Hurst assistant manager Financial
accountant Mike's first meeting welcome
Mike John Snell corporate manager
internal audit Sarah wilock director of
Customs digital transformation and
Improvement Joe Hobs corporate manager
of strategic policy and Theresa furn the
risk management lead we also have an
attendance councelor Andy melon the mids
district council member for performance
and resilience and alist mcro um baby
District Council Cabinet member for
customers digital transformation and
Improvement welcome everybody I'll move
to the meeting at self now apologies for
absent Bethany please thank you chair we
have apologies from apologies from
councelor Simon darling and councelor
Isabelle Reese thank you um any
Declaration of pecuniary and
non-pecuniary interests by members if so
um let me know please
now no you're all
good um jic 23 St 11 to confirm the
minutes of the meeting held on the 25th
of
September um that's for accuracy of the
minutes um can I have a proposal please
oh there loads we'll take we'll take
John and second uh um the other John
John me yep John W to propose John M to
Second thank
you thank you chair that vote is now in
progress
e
councelor patet may I take your V
verbally councelor Marriott may I take
your vote verbally
please
thank you chair there is six votes for
and two exstension so that's carried
thank you very Bethany um do we have any
petitions none received chair questions
by the public none received chair and
questions by counselors none received
chair thank you very much we'll get on
to the um bulk of the meeting now J
2312 um
management half yearly
report and I think that's Mike to take
us through that one please is that
correct thank you
chair
so the uh treasur management report
you'll be pleased to hear given his
nature is not a particularly
exhilarating one this time I think we'd
be in trouble if it was um so I'll give
you the highlights and be happy to take
any questions um given the economic
environment at the moment
with high inflation increasing
unemployment Plumbing to consumer
confidence and uh High interest rates
that they've recently been held at
5.25% we be pleased to hear that BG's uh
Opera in accordance with the approved
treasury management strategy and
complied with all the treasury man
management
indicators I do I do apologize it's that
EAS it's that better
should I should I ask
again okay so bayberg operates in
accordance with all the uh treasury
management
indicators um and operates in accordance
with the treasury management
strategy Miss suff has done the same say
for one breach of uh the um one breach
for one day which am maned to having too
much money in the bank account for one
day negligible
impact the credit risk scores were all
within the uh Benchmark a a rated credit
ratings uh given the uh paress times
we've operated prudently and cautiously
with uh Bayer's count overall debt
reducing by 9.2 million and M suff Deb
reduce them by 10.1 million this brings
their borrowing requirement to uh 112
million for bayberg and 100 million for
miduk over to Investments uh Bayer's
investment balances range between uh 12
a half million and 23 and a half million
M suuk Investments balances
corresponding in range between 11.2
million and 25.1 million movements being
down to time differences between income
and
expenditure one point notice that our
average rate of return is significantly
higher than thear range of our advisor
our our in closes other
clients um as the highlights each
council tax has uh 11 million of
externally managed P Equity property and
multi-asset funds where short-term
security and liquidity are lesser
considerations and the primary
objectives instead are regular Revenue
income and long-term price
stability since the date of the initial
Investments there have these generated
an total income return of 3.68 million
for bayberg and 3.53 million for Miss an
average return for the period of
3.93% I think this covers the points of
note from the treasury uh reports but
I'm happy to take any
questions yes questions please from the
coun anything your
want to improve or un happy with offer
clarifications uh councelor McLaren
please thank you chair I've got quite a
few but I'm happy to go with my first
one and then allow the
other okay
right thank you very much chair
um in terms of regulatory oversight
which we find in the report we've got
the SI for code we've got Quality
Reporting to the treasury and we've got
a joint training management strategy can
you advise me if we've got if there is
any external regulatory body I mean I
was around in the days of the audit
commission have we today got that sort
of external regulatory body that
oversees treasury Management in each
Council thank you
chair
yes thank you uh there's the sit for
code which we're obliged to comply with
and so we're measured against that
that's an external body which measures
our uh our our investment
strategy I just just come back on
that so there is no at no point there
could be somebody from outside coming in
to um make sure that our reports are
accurate well again say um we use we
rely on external advisor Island close
for all our strategy strategies they've
got great skill in the workplace and but
uh sit for our an external body uh which
set various indicators and uh measures
which we have to comply with and so in
effect they're the policeman for this
and make sure that we operate prudently
and uh
well thank you CH I'll go on to my
second question okay um on page 18
2.18 there's an an advice against
lending to two specific um
councils um now can you advise me if
that's part of the P wlb scheme or is it
a form of local Authority borrowing I
wasn't quite clear about that thank
you
for you chair thank you um no so this is
not part of the pwl borrowing this is
just local authority to local Authority
lending um and the credit ratings are
done through irland close as well so we
we make sure that we don't lend to any
councils that are below you know the
credit rating that's not
acceptable thank
you uh thanks chair yeah I hope I'm
reading this correctly on page
20 um the table I think says that
um we decided to pay 8 million off the
90 million loan at a rate of interest
rate of 2.6 why do we choose to do that
rather than paying um more of the
short-term borrowing amount which is
clearly got a higher interest
rate because that would obviously
saved
money yeah so the the loans have um
maturity date so when we take a loan out
with a local Authority even if it's a
long-term loan it's got a maturity date
so if we were to repay that any earlier
there would be penalties for that and
because the rates were so low when we
took them out it it seemed prudent to
let that kind of run to to maturity so
it's it's usually the maturity date that
fixes when we repay the loan rather than
any decision we take internally if you
like yeah thank you chair yeah I I just
wanted to um kind of gently for new
members say that the um the
astonishingly large um 94 million pounds
um of of borrowing uh that that is
essentially the mortgage on our Council
houses um so it's not quite as alarming
as as it might
look thank
you
don't I've got two more but I'm happy to
go with
okay
okay on page
23 uh we see the P wlb
facility can somebody advise me which
sort of projects we might use that for
within babber District Council thank
you yeah so um that would be a decision
we would probably take of any Capital
scheme that comes through to a council
for decision um so the recommendation
would probably have attached to it that
we would enter into a pwb loan and the
rate and the maturity of that loan so it
would be a decision that would be
taken thank you
m and my second question um it's
actually came up in my
ward uh when we look at the two councils
in these
papers uh there are distinct differences
between the level of mone's
available uh I know there are good
reasons for those differences but
because it came up in a public Arena I
would like to
clarify
um what are the reasons that Baba finds
itself in a different financial position
say to Mid suffk just very simply
actually thank
you yeah um it it's it's a historical
one as well so I think if we look back
over the years Baba had a history of
freezing council tax for a number of
years so that is a loss of cumulative
income over the years that that decision
was taken to freeze the council tax um
there are other factors that play into
it as well so because mids suffk has had
a lot more housing growth they've
benefited from a large amount of new
homes bonus um that has been received
every year it started off six years new
homes bonus that we received and then it
dropped to four years worth so it's
quite a significant amount of money um
and so you've got council tax you've got
new homes bonus and also the business
rates for babber are you know you
generate more income from business rates
as well so those are really your three
funding sources for both councils and
they are they are very
different thank you I just felt it was
important because it was raised in a
public space the public can listen to
this meeting and and read the agenda
papers and I think people need answers
actually thank you very
much I'm not
sure
okay so on page uh 28 have a
question could uh you confirm that we're
going to respect the uh legislation
which is coming in on that point
1.15 and what exposure is miduk going to
take in terms of the write down which we
will be implementing in thank
you yeah we certainly will be adhering
to that that legislation if that does
come through um as for us to follow so
we certainly will do um what will be the
impact will be whatever the value of
those Investments are at the time so at
the year end they'll be valued and then
any loss will need to account for that
correctly now I I can't articulate what
the double entry accounting and and all
of that is at the moment we we'll need
to explore into that a bit more but
it may mean that we need to set some
money aside to cover that loss should
that come through so we we will be
working that through if that legislation
does become a
requirement uh thank you because at the
moment rough calculations looks like
it's about 1.6
million so
that's okay thank
you
thank you chair sorry um yeah I'm
pleased to see on page 32 that we've now
um divested ourselves from funding
Circle but I just wondered what the
actual process was in terms of chasing
the outstanding bad debts is that
something that we do ourselves or
through funding
Circle yeah that's managed through
funding Circle so they do they do
actively try and recover the debts on
our behalf so yeah they do undertake
that
work yeah thank thank you chair um yeah
on councelor Davis question there um I
think the the paragraph
117 um is suggesting that we we won't um
we won't need to to be obliged sorry we
won't be obliged to to put the loss into
our accounts uh at the moment and the
minister wants to confirm
that yeah at the moment it's not a not
requirement but obviously we are
planning for and thinking ahead to
should that come to fruition yeah it's
not a requirement at the moment
confirmed thank you chair um yeah I've
got some questions relating to the
tables for cifco and the like the the
holding companies p uh the page yeah
that's why I was looking to buy myself
some time here sorry I think it's
4 34
yes because
um could I request or suggest that some
additional information needs to be added
to this sort of table in that it's
giving a cumulative net interest
received but it doesn't specify the time
period that the 10 million
or similar is actually been generated so
it would be helpful to have that
included in some shape or
form
um also the overall debt in the
situations of CCO and likewise I guess
with Gateway 14 would be helpful to be
added because you get the impression
that minutes as a as a debate from this
de you I was requesting that these
tables be further augmented sh if that's
possible oh for future reference yes
yeah for future reference um there's no
way that we could get that information
in for this particular meeting but for
subsequent meetings yeah I'm with you
now yeah it would be helpful to
counselors to get the whole picture of
these Investments because there's
significant um changes in valuations of
the properties which we purchased in the
order of 18 million which is not
transparent in this set of uh
information we get that as um a report
to council councelor Davis
you you want it better than that
or it is in when sico report to Council
it those sort of details come out then
that's true CH yes it's just that
perhaps I'm incorrect my assumption is
that with this audit meeting we're
looking at all the risks okay
financially that our council is exposed
to and in the case of these holding
companies we're getting information
which is very good to look at but
doesn't give the whole picture in my
humble opinion yep okay Melissa is that
something you could take I think you're
looking at it from probably a different
perspective here so this is the
council's um borrowing and uh income
investment you'd see that information
about the um property valuations in the
cifco business plan that comes forward
and Emily frequently brings forward that
update so that's from a company's point
of view so our risk and our investment
is what you're seeing here that loss of
assets does not is not an impact for the
council if you like it that's limited to
CCO um the company itself so that's
where you'd see that information it's
not really relevant for our borrowing
and our um interest repayments is the
only thing that we get from cifco from a
council
perspective thank you
although perhaps it's not the uh correct
place on the agenda because the
Financial Risk since we are the sole
shareholder of those companies still
rests with us as a
council
I think you'd probably see that more in
the statement of accounts where we show
our investment our share of the
investment in CCO is probably where you
would see that more than than in this
kind of report
here thank you and is it possible to
just looping back to this um cumulative
net interest received to
give thank you
it helps anyway I would think thanks
chair yes yeah okay councel mson yeah I
I I stopped on this same um this this
same table that that Council Davis just
referred to and I thought you know what
what are we actually saying here and and
I felt as if it would be more
understandable we get into these kind of
semi internal um
transactions um the if we interest
receivable is loans
to um
CCO and and interest payable is loans
from CCO Etc and you know the other
companies and whether that that would
help to make it more kind of transparent
to the lay um the lay um resident
looking at
it yeah we can try and make it a bit
clearer so just for clarification
interest receivable is the loan to CCO
and interest payable is the loan Council
has for with pwl so we can make try and
make it a little bit more understandable
in that table
certainly um if I understood Council
Davis's question correctly I think he
was asking for um interim valuations on
cifco bear in mind this is a halfe
report um we wouldn't be expecting our
valuers to be doing interim valuations
on c i that be unreasonable and you know
a lot Mis
expense Council from Cisco themselves
with the information and I presume
that's still um on the internet
somewhere isn't it the report still
exist um but but you're both midu
counselor but I presume you get the same
info that Baba does so I I presumed it
was all that but um I'm sure Melissa if
she can do anything to help or make it
clearer we we'll do
so any other questions points to
raise okay there was one for me that we
did talk about in The Briefing and
that's the um 84 million loan on the HRA
um I I I I don't know when it starts
being paid back but I presume we're
putting money aside from the HRA to take
care of that when it comes in um yeah I
think maybe it's something other members
ought to know because obviously um
things are going to change when we start
paying big lumps back so maybe um for
clarity Melissa you could just um
comment on that please yeah absolutely
so the maturity dates of those H PW
loans go sort of up to 2050 um I think
there is a table in the report that kind
of shows when the maturity is there like
a graph that shows the um the points but
what we are doing currently as part of
the HRA 30-year business plan is
building in when those loans mature and
the refinancing that we have to set
aside to cover that so that will all be
wrapped up in the affordability of that
HRA business plan so we're looking at
the maturity dates and and what the
refinancing options might be on those
loans as they as they
mature that's correct isn't
it
so yes I did wonder about 2030 some of
us may not be here then might
we but um okay yeah that was just for
clarity that obviously we've borrowed um
considerable funds 84 million from B to
buy our own houses back um effectively
sorry about that but um the other day of
reckoning will come so um be prepared
councelor
Davis uh thank you chair it's more of a
uh a short thank you from me after my uh
carping recently um on page 14 really
quite excited to see that uh our
treasury team is progressing the
ESG options so that I'm looking forward
to seeing those options explained on the
uh January
meeting so thank you team look to
progress that I think councelor Davis at
the right time and in the right way so
yeah we do have a
start any more items for debate or
questions before we go to the
vote no we're all clear
good just a little bit of help here
Bethany we need to take two and three
first is that
correct
I I need
a I need a proposal second one which one
should I take first is
it we do the joint one first okay my
propos second uh um for the first one 31
please
um I can do that from the chair if you
like and and and John is yep you go the
next turn
um so I'm proposing and John Ma and as
co-chair is um is second
in thank you chair that vote is now in
progress for all
members
thank you chair that is eight votes for
that's
unanimous now item
32 no
that that needs to be
um a bab member obviously doesn't it so
um oh yes yep um mer proposed him to
second thank
you thank you chair that vote is now in
progress for bam M
Bon
thank you chair that is three votes for
that's carried thank you very much I'm
relieved at
that and item 3.3 for mids
suff um alist to propose John to
Second thank you chair that vote is now
progress with mids suffk Members
Only
thank you chair that is five VES four
that's
carried thank you very
much
okay moving on JC 23 stroke 13 the
midterm internal audit
reports and I think that will be John I
presum yes thank you John I got so many
notes here I'm confusing them but thank
you far away thank you chair and good
morning
counselors the purpose of this report
that you have in front of you is to
inform you of the work that internal
order of undertaken for the first half
year of 2023 24 and it also provides
members with a review of the variety and
scope of projects and corporate
activities which are supported through
the work of the
team what I want to do now is just
provide you with some of the key
messages that I think are important
important that need to be drawn out from
the report uh for your
consideration firstly the unplanned
Demand on internal audit services to
provide Assurance support and guidance
on our diverse range of activities it's
actually formidably increased uh which
also includes the counter fraud work um
what I would uh provide members with a
level of assurances that's currently
being managed but um just to advise you
that we do have a relatively small team
um that I actually manage and so
obviously additional work is um can have
quite a bit of an impact as I said that
I am currently managing through various
sources but just to draw your attention
to to that in line with the council's
internal audit Charter the work has been
conducted to ensure it delivers against
the public sector internal audit
standard which I'm required to um comply
with and also helps me to produce the
annual head of internal audit opinion at
year end so the work centers around
governance processes monitoring
Arrangements ethical issues information
governance and counter fraud
management if we move on to the uh
appendix a uh of the work that's
completed again I just want to draw your
attention to a number of audits that I
think that um you'll pick up on so there
were three reviews uh that returned an
audit opinion on the control environment
of limited Assurance at the end of the
last Financial year that was 2022 23
where actions were outstanding but
obviously have been kept under review by
the audit team uh and I'm pleased to
report that management has been very
receptive in terms of the
recommendations that were made so they
refer to the general ledger audit the
election costs and the safeguarding so
if I take those in in that order so the
general ledger piece of work again it's
useful that Melissa's here but the the
work that we produced uh raised a couple
of issues and it's been agreed with
Melissa that those actions we've taken
forward as a part of the transformation
Financial transformational work work
that her and her team are currently
undertaken in terms of election costs um
you would have been aware that there
were a number of issues around this and
again I'm very pleased to report that uh
management have taken on board the
recommendations from internal a it and
they've embedded those into a very
robust action plan that's currently
being worked on and this report will be
produced and also circulated to the new
elections uh manager that starts uh mid
January in terms of the safeguarding
audit again I'm pleased to report that
we did a followup and the
recommendations following that have
actually been imple
implemented if we move on to this
particular year um again there were
three reports with an audit opinion of
limited Assurance one was around
expenses which are put through Oracle
and internal audit testing um looked at
a sample of approved expenses and we
found that in a number of instances the
council policies were not always being
followed uh and I think there may be a
reason for this that sits behind it in
terms of perhaps a lack of confusion or
or misunderstanding of where uh
employees can consider they're now based
which sort of stems from the covid where
obviously during a period of time we
were asked to work from home obviously
now that's being lifted and we're
actually seeing more staff coming back
into the office um but the policies um
that we're supposed to be ADH here to
still Mak Endeavor house our um place of
employment not from home and I think
that's where the confusion has arisen
and we're working currently with um HR
and also Kathy Nixon the Strategic
director uh or the deputy chief
executive to form some words that we can
actually post out to all staff so
they're more uh akin to to our
policies the next area is around
procurement cards and this is where
Service uh area specific uh and again
I'd like to just reemphasize that some
of the areas that we found here weren't
material in terms of their value but
there were examples of non-compliance uh
with this policy under spending
lack of accurate descriptions recorded
under the items that were purchased and
therefore really wasn't clear whether we
were achieving uh value for
money these issues within the
procurement cards are actually being
addressed as a a piece a wider piece of
work uh undertaken by the corporate
manager we've also undertaken some work
around Building Services supplies and
this was a piece of work that was
commissioned by uh the director of
housing um the process in place for
managing Building Services suppliers
didn't align to the council's policies
uh and therefore again preventing any
assurance that the council were gaining
value for money the processes for
engaging supplies completion of work and
payment processing uh have evolved over
time which were found to be slightly
disjointed and unwieldly in practice
these recommendations have all been
accepted by the director of Housing and
again they are being put in place as we
speak now
as well as conducting uh a number of
audit reviews uh internal audit have
also had significant involvement within
a period in a variety of different
Council activities which include leading
on the production of the annual
governance statement uh for 2022
23 attending the council statutory
offices working group which I attend uh
under professional guidance in terms of
my governance uh
expertise also uh work around the
antifraud corruption uh and this report
uh will be it's an annual report and it
will come to this committee uh and be
presented by myself uh in March and
there's also uh a number of as you'll
probably be aware of government
initiatives around business grants and a
member of my team helps and supports
that business cell and again that's
quite lengthy in terms of resources and
obviously we're now looking at uh the
flood uh uh relief payments as well
again my member staff is uh heavily
involved in that uh to ensure that those
payments reach the right people and
there's due diligent checks that sit
behind
that uh there are no additional issues
relating to this report so I'm happy now
to take uh questions thank
you right thank you John on the three
with the um limited Assurance your
confident that these will be um sorted
out in this current year are you which
we're sort of halfway through already
aren't we really uh yes chair so part of
the process where a a piece of work and
audit work has been given a limited
Assurance or poor Assurance we do follow
up on those recommendations and I can
give provide Assurance to these members
today that all the recommendations that
being forward of being accepted by
management so it's a case of following
those up at the required time and then
reporting that at year
end yeah thank you is it is it again a
resource issue staff to do the work as
at large you say you've got a small team
and that's obviously a problem is
it uh it is um we tend to cut our cloth
accordingly so I can shave days off
other audits without having a
significant impact on the controll
environment that we test um but
obviously the more reports that come out
limited assurance that more work has to
be required to put into the followup
work um but as I said at the moment it's
manageable but as I said I just wanted
to raise uh this particular point to
members
today are we actively trying to recruit
back up another member of Staff or or
maybe not
then I would look in Melissa's Direction
but probably Melissa wouldn't look back
no okay well we'll probably I think the
question was um John's got a small team
they're obvious struggling to do
everything in time and some of this may
have risen through a lack of Staff in
the first place so my question was are
we trying to get back up are we trying
to recruit staff or or financially
that's may not be possible I I just
think to set the scene for the question
to debate it's nice to know things from
the front Melissa I think obviously
across the council you know directors
are responsible and corporate managers
are responsible for resourcing their
teams accordingly whether that be like
John's with a contract through tier or
internal staff um so it's not really
something you know we're not I would say
we haven't got like a vacancy freeze or
anything like that but obviously it is
challenging to recruit to vacant posts
at the moment and I can speak from
experience in my service area um where
I'm finding it very challenging to get
get the right people um in
so yeah I think we're mindful of that
nobody wants to be an auditor anymore do
they nationally or locally um yeah sad
okay uh well that's the basis of where
we are counselors um questions from the
floor please yeah councilor register you
were first far away um I thought I knew
procurement can you explain procurement
cards because I don't know this
to sorry I looked at Melissa because
know excuse me Alissa is going to answer
that but it's effectively like credit
cards and there are limits set to that
um and there authorization limits and
those people that are given procurement
cards um have to sign an undertaking to
comply with policies associated with
those
cards thank you chair yeah I've got I've
got a few but on the um if you could
look at page um 43 first uh the the
actual risk management of the um what
we're what we're um looking at um
um with with the point about un
unplanned demand which which comes
through um and the small team only point
and and of course I've I've um I've
asked about that a few times over the
years um I just wonder whether
actually the the um the likelihood of
the risk of slippage is actually three
not just unlikely um it sounds like it's
actually quite likely given the number
of of sort of additional things which
which are quite rightly um being being
the Departments are asking for internal
audit can you have a look at this that
we're intending to do please which is
essentially what unplanned work is um
you know I just wonder what actually
that if that was three um then the risk
register would would be saying a bit
more loudly to to um to the corporate
managers sorry well to to the director
and and the chief executive um that we
do need to expand this um Team a little
bit if we possibly can um really just a
comment on
that yeah thanks thank you counselor um
as I said sort of in in my introduction
the the unplanned work is increasing but
at the moment it's I would consider it
to be
manageable and as with any internal
audit program or what you approve at the
beginning of the year there is a degree
of flexibility and it's all risk-based
so I would then make a judgment in terms
of meeting expectations particularly for
management where a lot of the work would
come from in terms can we do it and if I
deem it to be sufficiently high risk
that could have an adverse effect on the
council then some of those audits that
we've been prior to have been agreed
would slip down the list if that makes
sense in terms terms of their order but
that would be a judgment for myself if I
felt we got to a particular point where
it would impact on my annual audit
opinion then that's when I'd be raising
it through um proper channels and
raising that through
SLT uh and then if I still had concerns
obviously I'd be raising it here um with
with members today U but at the moment
it's manageable and I can cut my cloth
accordingly without having a significant
impact but what I want want to do is
just raise it that there's a lot more
that's being placed on a relatively
small team um just for for your
attention at this stage but at this
stage I'm still happy that the scoring
remain remains as two however if that
changed then obviously I could escalate
that to three and raise it through the
proper
channels is that that sub subject
effectiv is just continuous review um
all through the year because there's
continuous requests and demands put on
on internal audit and I have to manage
expectations so I have In fairness
turned people away and saying actually
I'm sorry in terms of risk that's not a
high risk on my radar uh in terms of the
council exposure and that's my
professional judgment um and others that
I will cut cordingly as I said the
director of housing came through and
asked him from additional work around
Building Services and bearing in mind
the situation there that deemed to be
that work was
necessary yes thank you yes I I'll I'll
rate it as a two and a half I think
thank
you as John sign there is a cost of
Staff which somebody has to pay for
probably the council taxpayers at the
end of the day hence it's a higher up
decision but yeah thank you John you're
obviously doing your best and trying to
get an order and keep all the balls in
the air um councelor maret
please hello um I see I obviously Pro
related to the um few staff that you've
got I see several of the audits um
you've identified good practice but then
there no further actions listed I just
wanted to refer though to the um the
audit around register of gifts um
interest and Hospitality as a newcomer
to the council I'm sort of not really
familiar with the processes um involved
in that and um I'm really surprised to
some extent that people are allowed to
to take gifts and um is there any
guidance as to what gifts it is
appropriate to take and is there sort of
any
pre-approval um of of taking gifts and
hospitality is there any line manager
involvement are we talking uh staff and
members or just
staff um both I
guess um my auton sort of advice was
don't accept um uh then you're not
compromised or the perception of being
compromised I do appreciate that
sometimes it's very difficult and very
awkward not to receive gifts but if you
do have to receive them obviously there
is a process in terms of recording those
uh and again after each of the meetings
you will ask in terms of Declarations of
Interest so that's an opportunity every
time that you come to a committee or
cabinet or Council to then raise those
but there is guidance within um members
guidance on gifts and hospitalities and
Declarations of interests similarly
those with um officers as well um I can
take this offline and and perhaps myself
and Jan can give you a little bit more
detail that sits behind that if you if
you wish but my first response would be
I would recommend that you don't accept
gifts or Hospitality to be honest um
even though it might be slightly awkward
embarrassing by telling the person who's
perhaps being genuine that you you can't
because of your position and the
perception that might be seen by
others thank
you when we're elected we all get a do
and don'ts um sheet in the pack I would
think yes Jan is not nodding um so
basically um please don't take any brown
envelopes or anything else okay any
councelor M please thank you yeah I I've
got two two others um one is on the um
election costs um I wonder whether
there's any um confirmation we can get
now that the um arguments and disputes
coming from Parish councils um on the
subject um have all been satisfactory
resolved thank you chair um if I could
just come in on that so we we've had um
a few not not many disputes um most of
them now are resolved I think we've just
got one
outstanding yeah last one um yeah the I
I was just wondering actually this is
again on the on the risk um risk
management um
the reporting this is the second One
issues raised by internal audit
appropriately actioned or not
appropriately actioned Etc um so the the
reporting I just wondered what the the
actual reporting Arrangement is um for
for all you know sort of negative audit
findings um you know who are they
reported to and how
frequently thank you counselor so every
piece of work excuse me will result in
an audit report
now depending on the findings uh the
priority ratings and the degree of risk
will depend in terms of the audience so
what would normally happen the auditee
will receive the report the corporate
manager will receive the report where we
have limited Assurance or poor that will
be escalated up to um the director and
we only had a conversation at SLT the
other day where um whether those reports
need to be um presented by by myself
stroke the director uh around full SLT
uh and that's something that Arthur is
going to have a look at and come back to
me on but I can assure you that any uh
report that has a priority One rating
limited Assurance gets escalated up to
the director and has followed up and
gets reported on um back at this
committee McLaren
please thank you
chair I just want to say first of all
John thank you for a very comprehensive
report um but I do have some
concerns um if we go with the premise
that risk management is everybody's
business then that is everybody in the
organization and some of the things in
your report that were identified were
actually um knowledge and competence of
Staff or the processes that were
identified that were not which for you
in that report which of those two things
is probably
the premier
concern thank
you I I think um and again touching upon
what Melissa was saying and I think
raised by the chair about
resources
um some of the issues that we have found
there has been changes in staff and I if
if I'm being brutally honest um to to
you guys here today I think sometimes
the Handover arrangements from a person
that's just about to leave and a new
member being appointed coming in I don't
think are quite as good as they need to
be so they're picking up stuff and
there's obviously some errors that don't
get addressed straight away but they do
further on down the line so my sense you
know it's round about Staffing having
the right caliber staff with the right
skill sets to do the job um we're all
under a huge amount of pressure as as
members at you are as well but that' be
one sort of concern that I would have
that sometimes we have relatively new
members of staff that come in we also
have a number of interims uh as well
that will come in do a job won't
necessarily pass that knowledge base on
to staff and then leave and then we're
almost back to square one so there is
something I think as an organization we
need to to learn from particularly with
the Handover Arrangements which I think
are crucial to ensure that sort of
continuity of of business and making
sure that
those controls the control environment
isn't weakened in any
way thank you
John taking up on that another Point how
seamlessly is the um
the remote staff and the inhouse staff
um does that cause a problem or is that
working as well as it can
be I think it's um very much as a
corporate manager myself it's down to
myself and directors to make sure that
there is a a
presence um now whether you're working
from home or in the office I think one
of the benefits I found personally is
coming into the office now probably a
couple of days a week is what I missed
by working at home was that rich
intelligence about bumping into people
at the coffee machine having sitting you
know around uh my colleagues picking up
conversations sometimes you don't get
that if you're working from home but my
my sense is that it's down to the
corporate manag to make sure that their
staff that they're responsible for have
that knowledge base and if they feel
it's slipping in in any way then that
needs to be addressed but I do
appreciate the Some people prefer
because of Co like to work from home um
but it's important that we don't lose
that
knowledge if they're remotely working as
opposed to occasionally coming into the
office and I think from a health and
wellbeing there's all sorts of issues
here from a health and well-being I
think it's quite healthy to come in and
actually have those
conversations not just work solitary
from
home yes it's not really a question it's
a statement John I think sometimes um if
there's a team and um maybe the head of
the team is inh house and some of the
staff aren't or vice versa I think you
do lose something but there are huge
benefits to all staff to work from home
as well but we've just got to get the
best of um both haven't we and I think
as well there's a responsibility from
all of us to share knowledge when we
have it yes you know whatever location
we're working from
yes all the best tips are picked up over
the coffee machine absolutely yeah it
it's just a point members that we must
be careful not to lose the um the bonom
really between staff and even counselors
when they come in there's a lot to be
said for good interaction Council
register please um taking up that last
Point um do any of the Departments
operate uh their own shared resource or
Wiki um as I would call it in my
business uh so that people could if you
want to find out how something operates
how process works or um the funding for
something then you can the the knowledge
of previous people is is is put in there
so that you can retrieve that data when
you need and if that isn't being done by
anyone is there possibly a requirement a
need to do that set that
up I mean certainly if we found that in
our internal audit reports that would be
raised when be talking about the
Handover arrangements and we have in the
past uh raised that very issue so again
it's down the responsibility of
management whatever level to ensure when
new staff come in that the pro policies
and procedures that oping that are
operating to uh correctly Fred so they
have that knowledge base to hit the sort
of Road running as I said it's not
always happened in the past uh and
that's what I've mentioned before where
there is a slight risk of that happen
happening so as I said I think from an
organizational point of view yes there
are some lessons to be learned in that
aspect but I think you know as long as
we take responsibility and we know when
people are going to be leaving and when
people are going to be joining the
organization it's down to managers like
myself to make sure that um the new
member of Staff has the correct tools to
actually do the
job um Council of whiteed
please thank you um looking at page uh
50 um that sets out the table it sort of
defines the audit opinions from
substantial through to reasonable
limited and no Assurance I mean
obviously it's correct to focus on the
limited Assurance where you might have
significant gaps weaknesses or
non-compliance but um my question really
is um to to corporate manager is um this
time we seem to have no reports coming
through with substantial assurance and
so I guess the question for for us the
perhaps the new committee is is
reasonable Assurance reasonable or or or
should we be you know looking more for
substantial Assurance across the board
what what what should the aspirations of
the committee and perhaps even The Wider
Council be in terms of um uh going
between reasonable and
substantial
that's a very sort of open
question not just for me to answer I'm
mean an Ideal World yes everything would
be lovely if it was substantial
Assurance
invariably I have to be careful what I'm
going to say here because I never like
to give substantial Assurance because we
do limited testing so we're not doing
100% testing we're only doing limited
testing so I'm very reluctant to say and
report to members here that everything
is has a substantial Assurance because I
think that would be unwise I think in
terms of caution I tend to put it more
reasonable if we found something in
terms of our principle and testing to be
absolutely perfect then I don't have any
hesitation on giving substantial
Assurance but generally we will find odd
things that just haven't been quite
right whether it's dotting of an i
Crossing of a t and therefore I can't
put it substantial Assurance um I think
it's always slightly dangerous and I
know colleagues my fellow colleagues in
the audit will will probably share that
slight concern if you start putting
things of substantial Assurance you have
to be pretty sure that everything is
perfect and we don't have the resources
to do a 100% check so that's why I'm
very reluctant to to perhaps put
substantial Assurance uh to give that an
opinion moving
forwards um because I think um where we
use a s term substantial I think e suff
use the term effective and when
use the term good so they all share the
term reasonable but effective good or
substantial do you think their
definitions perhaps um weaker than yours
in terms of substantial istic s
aspiration that's very high um in terms
of the actual audit opinions um it
wasn't that long ago that um I belong to
a suff wide group heads of audit and we
actually started looking at what
opinions each of us were giving and this
is actually buil around Si's opinions so
we have adopted those and many of the
others I think there are one or two that
are slight differences but when you look
at a reasonable it's when you look at
the definition of what's being put it's
not too dissimilar at all you might be
some put effective I put a reasonable
but most of us within software put
reasonable one or two I think might put
effective but effective effectively
sorry and good was the top one they all
use the term reasonable yeah but they
when you use substantial they say
effective and other say good I I think
in some ways it's a play on words I
think I'd be more interested in the
actual definition that sits behind
it thank you chair um one thing I've
sort of noticed on the um the health of
the organization
chart that we're looking at and I
highlighted this as well on our last
meeting when we were looking at the uh
elections report and the issues that we
have with the elections is that the
follow-up dates well there are no dates
but the sort of the follow-up action is
always very vague so
there's no one seems to sort of take
responsibility of when things need to be
done by and it would be this this is a
midterm report so the the the follow-up
Act it it's just there's a general 23 24
but if this is a midterm report that
means we know when the full report is
coming out so it'd be very easy to put a
date on it so how how can we how can we
properly audit and sort of manage and
supervise if we've got no end goals if
we've got no no standard set and and
also we don't really know who's doing
the follow-up actions as well it's it's
quite a you you look at some of these
things in
isolation and we don't know where it's
come from who's following it up who we
need to be chasing up to properly audit
so I think what we need is a is a Racey
Matrix a racy diagram do everyone happy
what I mean by a racy Matrix I think you
need to explain to some of the offices
and also members okay so that's F so
it's quite common in in business and in
government a racing Matrix is raci who
is responsible accountable who is cons
consulted who is informed um and and we
we do use it for some things I think in
bmsd but this would be a good example on
definitely on on
audit um of where we should have
follow-up dates a setting Stone date
where the sort of managers and directors
can assess something by and then in
conjunction with the racy
Matrix um us as counselors we we know
who is actually responsible for doing
that follow-up action um and also who
who's in that chain so yeah it's sort of
adding more more meat to the Bone
because otherwise it seems that
responsibility accountability
culpability is just sort of diluted and
gone and and we don't actually you know
we don't know who these people are and
when they're going to do these things by
the follow-up
action comment on that John um excuse me
I think what the council is talking
about with what youve just mentioned was
actually would be in our reports you
would have to have the whole
report um I can summarize it
particularly for those that have come up
with a deliber to assurance that I can
but internal audit would follow it up we
would have ownership of the
recommendations for followup and we can
have some time frames as the counselor
was saying for followup so I can provide
those moving forwards certainly if that
would would help you otherwise you'll
have an unworldly report that's going to
run into pages and pages and there are
some sensitive stuff there that I'd be a
little bit concerned about sharing in
The Wider um audience uh to be perfectly
honest so um but I understand where the
council is coming from so I can provide
that little bit more detail otherwise
you're going to have the whole report
but what the council is saying is in
would be included in the actual report
itself that we could then manage so I'm
I'm happy to do that
counselor at the end isn't it it's a
bunch of work that will be done when
it's done you're
saying each of those recommendations is
said has ownership and there's a time
frame associated with that so the report
three reports for this year will be
reported at year end anyway to give you
that Pro provide that level of assurance
that we have actually folded up but I
understand where the council is coming
from so providing this I can actually
put a little bit more meat to the bones
if you like to give obviously council's
assurance that there is clear uh
responsibility and ownership and a time
frame associated with those
recommendations okay you're happy with
that Council as it is right thank you um
any other questions or debate to take
place
um no well we'll move to the noting then
please um I need a proposal in a second
to denote this Bethany that's correct
isn't it yet John is um
proposing uh Council register to miss
second
in thank you chair that vote is now in
progress
ethy will write down what we say so
that's the start of a steer if there
something you're not entirely happy
with you're struggling Council McLaren
may take your vot
verbally thank you chair that is eight
votes for that's unanimous thank
you I'm mindful that a couple of
counselors have got to leave I think um
before the end of the meeting so moving
on to 23 stroke4 the annual risk
management strategy update and if I
remember that's Teresa to take that is
that correct or the PO Alisa first isn't
it Andy sorry go for it yeah thank you
chair um so I'm jointly presenting this
um this paper this report with um my
colleague a mcro who's the the portfolio
holder um responsible at Baba and then
we have officers um Joe Hobbs who's
corate manager of the Strategic policy
unit Teresa furn who's the risk
management lead and then uh Sarah wilock
who's the director under wish this all
sits um so I'll kick off and then I'll
hand over to Alis to um complete the
picture so this this uh risk management
paper sets out the context and provides
an update particularly for new members
of the committee uh in summary over the
last couple of years the council has
moved risk management away from AIT into
a new unit for strategic policy and
we've also in that time adopted the risk
management principles that are set out
in his Majesty's government's orange
book which is the management of risk
principles and
Concepts um I would describe us as being
on a journey of transformation and
Improvement and on that Journey we are
using the recommendations from two
places one is the the process of audit
which is carried out by Tia who are our
business Assurance providers and the
second one is the outcomes of our
corporate peer challenge which happened
in 2022 now this is where we had a as a
as a council we invited in a team of um
officers and counselors from other
councils organized by the LGA as as a as
a challenge to our organization and
we're still working through those
recommendations so the work still to be
done from these recommendations is that
cabinet members uh in particular
portfolio holders need to become
familiar with the risk register as it
applies to their
portfolios and and both cabinets have a
presentation on risk coming to Cabinet
briefing on the 12th of December and
from this each cabinet will develop a
risk appetite statement and there's
various levels of risk which are
detailed on page 66 of the risk
management policy and statement which is
attached at appendex one so there are
five levels of risk from averse to
egoer uh we also need to do some work in
finance to review our financial
Assurance thresholds and also improve
our Financial Risk
analysis um now members of of the joint
audit
and committee have have asked previously
for more information about our company's
risk Arrangements we have as you know
mids B Holdings we have mids growth
Gateway 14 and
CCO paragraphs 4.16 through to
416.16 point5 whilst the companies
manage their own risks risks posed to
the companies posed by the companies to
the councils are managed through the
joint strategic risk register so I hope
that covers off that point but I'll hand
over to Alistair to add some more
detail thanks very much Andy yes if
Andy's doing the play bypl I'm here for
the color um commentary seques um just
wanted to emphasize for new members that
this approach to risk manag mement
introduced a year ago um is a systematic
approach whereas perhaps in the past it
might be said that the risk assessments
or risk analysis was a little bit more a
morphous with each directorate having
its own
assessments the orange book and our risk
management strategy go at this in a
systematic way and as an example and and
I'd like to bring it up specifically
because it addresses a point made by
councelor mat on the an earlier item uh
just taking one item the risk Matrix and
the scoring criteria should it be a two
2.5 or a three and here we have
systematic explanation of where the
levels lie in likelihood probability
impact and consequence and those
obviously are capable of being reviewed
and should be reviewed and will be
reviewed but the point I'm making is
that rather than being objective it can
be said to be properly subjective and I
think that's a useful um discipline for
the entire Council and the idea is to
embed um a risk management approach in
each and every directorate as I say
we're in the first year of that it's an
ongoing process you can see the circular
diagram in the report and I I actually
think we've we've come up with a really
good piece of work but it's not static
it's a living document and that's part
of our our job as counselors and your
job to keep us on board board uh to make
sure that we we have it embedded in the
council thank you very
much um yes thank you chair um yes thank
you uh for the outline there councilors
and just want to um add that we hope
that this uh paper gives the committee
here today assurance that the risk uh is
being taken um seriously and the right
mechanisms are in place to have that
Assurance um because ultimately we need
to make sure that we have the right
Frameworks in place to assess risk um so
then it can be then carried out
throughout the council so we hope that
this update to um the committee today
gives you that assurance that this is
happening thank you
chair moving to questions any points to
raise please are we all
happy canel Matson yeah I think more
more in the manner of of um of observ
ations and questions Sher if if if I may
um I've I've always felt um you know
from when I first saw the council's risk
registers quite a few years ago um you
know that we all and by all I mean all
members um you know in you know
constitutionally we are the
council and the
council um has these risks and and I
think you know identifying and um in the
sense that all
members understand that they
are have a share of that risk in that
sense is very important and um you know
I was just trying to remember
um you know quite a long time ago now
particular risk was identified probably
by internal audit in the first place
that um um we we weren't looking at our
trees the trees that were on Council
land and when they were looked at it
turns out there was a lot of things that
might fall down on people and the risks
were very real and very serious and I
think at that time it was going to the
scrutiny committee and the scrutiny
committee came back at the next meeting
and then the next meeting and said you
know have you done this yet have you
done this yet so I I think that getting
more members to understand that their it
is our risks is is very important and so
I I wanted to propose that um we we
organize further risk training for
committee members but also that we make
it available to all the other members um
so I i' um that's what I would really
like to see us
do several questions in there that was
more of a debate actually wasn't it but
um Joe would you like to pick some of
those out of that please um yes and yeah
thank you for that councelor maton and
yes certainly we'd be very happy to
provide that uh further training to
members of J committee um and any other
counselors who wish to take um that
training offer up as well um ultimately
yes is everyone's concern risk it's a
it's a process to make sure that you
have Assurance as counselors that the
things that might keep you awake at
night are being adequately managed um
and that there is a mitigation plan in
place for for those risks so yes the
engagement with that um is always
welcomed so yes we can provide that
training we could build that into the
recommendation at the end um councilor
McLaren thank you chair can I say what a
comprehensive strategy is but if we
think back to the previous item on the
agenda which was about risk management
being everybody's bus business this is
quite a large document how are we going
to ensure that staff are
fully um cognizant with it and put it
into practice I'm just thinking of the
part-time member of Staff we talked
about people working from home but um
they're just as responsible to ensure
that this happens how are we going to
address that challenge thank
you
thank you councelor McLaren for your
question um we have recently built a
risk uh management portal and on the
risk management portal we've got
comprehensive training and guidance we
want that to be available to everybody
members and
offices and I am working with
directorates and services and
individuals um across both councils to
provide bespoke training um and work
shops wherever necessary so we're not
going for a sort of One-Stop shop we're
trying to um accommodate different
learning styles and um different context
as well because different Services have
got different
requirements
okay maret please hello regarding um
number n m register um system page 74 um
the deescalation of risks and um they
are de-escalated a service area program
or company risk registers onward
operational management I just wonder are
these de-escalated risks Revisited
strategically at any time you know it
would be quite easy to say oh you know
is this solved you know this isn't going
to happen again but as it has been a par
risk is there sort of any policy of
occasionally revisiting
them
thank you very much counselor so
de-escalated risks when they go back to
an operational or a program um RIS
register they will be under constant
surveillance so they're not necessarily
going to be closed so we have
directorate meetings monthly where
corporate managers will bring those risk
registers up for discussion with their
with their colleagues and with the
director and so they're constantly under
surveillance so they need to go if they
need to be um escalated again they can
be so we're constantly Vigilant about
what's on the risk registers and we've
got a new system coming in pentana Risk
which will help us look across risk
registers rather than just looking at
them in silos so we'll have even more
visibility thank
you question
please no no points to make in debate
we've had several in the questions
haven't we so we've covered two in one
really okay well we move to
um uh the electronic vote now this is
for just recommendations isn't it
Bethany and we've had and by Magic what
what I said suggested has appeared on
the um on the on the voting piece thank
you
second yes um proposer and second please
I can propose this and just look for a
second up Council register yep that's
fine and we've had a bit added on to um
what we're recommending and I think that
covers most things um how do you propose
Joe we do that you set out a time table
and maybe an online training or after
another meeting what would suit officers
best um yes I think we can uh go in come
up with the bit of an offer on that and
then circulate it to members and then in
discussion um you with yourselves andly
our cabinet members um just to make sure
that that's the right level of training
but we we'll go away and then come up
with a proposal to circulate to members
yes that sounds very practical in common
sense how do members feel add on to a
for an hour after the next meeting would
you be happy with that it's nice to be
able to talk about it as well as sit
online and do it virtually isn't it so
may be possible with the January meeting
or is that is that too short time
frame I think um that hour would be a
good starting point and then we can take
it from there really and see if there's
something further we needed to explore
okay so we're voting on that also which
I think is a good really good
strategy okay um it's all in blue so
please cast your votes yeah that that
vot is no
progress thank you chair that is eight
votes for that's
unanimous thank you
Bethany we'll progress now on to
2315 update on previous year's financial
situation and um that would be Melissa
won't it yes
thank you chair um yeah we've provided
this briefing update because um I think
it was a request from councelor Matson
and I think it's right that you you see
the situation of where we are with our
accounts and the outstanding audits that
we have um we the last accounts we had
audited were the
201920 accounts so ey are our Auditors
and that was the last opinion that we
had given on our accounts now this
committee would normally see those audit
plans and the audit opinions and also
the statement of accounts so it's
something you haven't got into a cycle
of seeing yet because of the the state
of where we are with with the audits um
and I think you can see in the report we
set out a paragraph uh just get to the
right
place uh so 2 point sort 2.3 and 2.4 we
talk about kind of where you know where
the the state of things are and we're
not alone um you can see there a figure
of 918 delayed audits across the country
so you know I would say we're a good
company but it's it's not a great
situation to to have that many accounts
unaudited um I think the situation the
latest that I've heard is that ey will
probably give limited Assurance on those
outstanding audits that are are open if
you like um but they will provide a
value for money conclusion probably on
the 22 23
audits I think it's fair to say that
this committee should take Assurance
from the work that John Snell's um
already uded to in terms of the audit
plan and and the internal audit work
that's done on the key financial
controls in addition to that we do
regular report the quarterly financial
performance and we have the credential
indicators in there we also as part of
the report you've seen this morning
where we're adhering to our treasury
code and our strategy as well so I think
there are checks and balances there to
make sure that we are doing things
correctly um but obviously it's not an
ideal situation to have four years
unaudited accounts kicking around and it
does impact on the team as well so the
Auditors are likely to come back in
January to do the 2020 21 audit we're
still trying to close the 2223 accounts
and publish those as well so and it's
the same people that are working on all
of this so as they're responding to
auditor queries they're trying to do the
accounts as well so it is putting a lot
of pressure on the team that are already
struggling as well so yeah I just wanted
to to bring that update really for for
your awareness so that you know the
situation and and if you're talking to
colleagues who across other councils are
are talking about similar things
hopefully you're informed enough to know
what the picture is but I'm happy to
take any
questions really is because without
audit we don't get a steer either do we
so um if something is wrong it could be
wrong twice I we all hope and pray it's
andure it's not but um there a bit
working blind um counselors what are
your views
Council register
first um I just find it astonishing that
we were there they still haven't
released uh audited accounts for so long
ago and we're trying to work out the
budget for
2425 it's
it's it in any any other business uh the
company's house would have gone spare by
that wouldn't they or or if it was a
charity the Charities commission would
have
fined and yet it seems every local
authorities is in the same boat are
these auditing companies just short of
Staff or short of skills or just short
of everything really and just can't Pro
work with the local authorities and do
the work in a reasonable
time is every briefing Council of
register it's not um natural progression
is it but um Everybody assures me
they're doing the best it's almost a
government thing really isn't at a
higher level but Melissa please um
reassure us yeah I think nationally
there is a there is staffing issues I
know all of the audit firms are
struggling and particularly local
government audit is very different to
private sector um auditing so I think
they are struggling to recruit people to
to those roles so yeah
yeah I I mean I heard last week that
price Waterhouse Coopers are laying off
Auditors it's Bonkers isn't it if
they're doing some of these auditing and
they're laying off Auditors what on
Earth is going
on is that the private sector pays more
and um than local government do I would
imagine is one of the
problems Council McLaren
I thought I saw another hand up yes yep
Council Clan first thank you thank you
chair Melissa if the we've been talking
about audit and assessing performance
and all that say we found
fraud would would that be impacted by
this late system or would would it be a
conflict
or I I think it's probably more likely
to be picked up through internal audit
if there was a fraud I think you know
rest assured that that's the work that
John and tia do so yeah I don't think
the so ey kind of focus on how we've
accounted for things and made sure that
we've treated things right under the
international financial reporting
standards to make sure that presentation
our accounts give a true and Fair View
so it's not necessarily looking at fraud
it's presentation have we accounted for
things correctly in the accounts if you
like thank you
Melissa Davis please uh thank you chair
so Minister when do you think our
Council would have actually got up and
had fully audited accounts for all the
years that's a very difficult question
to answer and yeah I would like to be
able to give you an answer but you know
if if e are coming back in January to do
the 2021 audits we've still to have the
conversation about whether they will do
a light touch for those other ones in
between or whether they will focus on
the value for money conclusion which
does tie in nicely to to the budget
setting as well it's how how financially
sustainable are we and what are we doing
to to make sure we are um so yeah sorry
I I honestly couldn't I wish I
could business if you're in trouble
you'd have two years to catch out but it
doesn't work that way well and we may
never catch up to be honest that's the
frightening thing um we may just end up
working years behind it's not great it
really isn't it's not good um not to
have a steer as to where we're going and
if something is wrong um we just live
with it councelor maton thank you chair
yes well firstly thanks for bringing
bringing this um briefing so that
everybody and and the public I mean I
think that the public um perception is
is is an issue here as well fortunately
we haven't seem to have had any any midu
citizens that have been asking questions
about this recently but they they they
did a few years ago when this we started
to get into this cycle of of delay and
then we failed to meet the the the date
that set out for the first time um and
someone was chasing us at that point but
just just make it clear where the
situation is now I've um since I became
chair joint chair um I have managed to
attend a couple of we
um where
um a government well the the
intermediaries that that set out you
know PSA AA and so on um have sought to
to offer a briefing as to to where this
is going and what they're trying to do
to resolve it and so on and um the the
government say they are going to make
some proposal
about how to resolve this and and
minister is is is um you know hinting at
some of those that our particular
auditor has um talked about but as far
as I know and as of about four or five
weeks ago um the government hadn't
decided what to do about this so we are
in that we are in that uncomfortable
place and I sh you know I wanted new
members to understand this situation
um that um it isn't particularly one of
our making um but it is an uncomfortable
place to be so um we'll no doubt we'll
get another briefing on that when it it
changes thank
you which government do you think will
be doing
this no
comment no um as co-chair Melissa some
something I often think about if the
council took on an ambitious project
that needed financing with the fact
we've got no ordered accounts for two
years make a difference to that you
can't get a bank loan if you got no
ordered accounts I know council's a bit
different and there's a reason for it
but um I just wonder sometimes is that a
weak link would it make a
difference I don't think so because
obviously you know we we have our credit
rating for uh borrowing from other local
authorities and obviously we've got pwb
boring there as well so I don't think
having unaudited accounts particularly
placed but it would be something I think
people would be thinking about as a risk
particularly with more council's you
know issuing section 114 notices as well
you know this is just another thing that
will not give you comfort I think if if
you were looking for it to invest in or
to lend some money to a council so
directly no but indirectly probably yes
okay thank you you've been very honest
Melissa but I'm sure myself my co-chair
will be raising this at every briefing
um as we would but we realize you're
doing the best um yeah thank you members
um any other points uh Council of
Whitehead yeah I mean I think it really
beggar belief that these big uh for
accounting companies you know can't
carry out these audits because not only
do they do local Authority audits but
they do company audits from the smallest
to the biggest and a limited company
well a company quot on the stock
exchange if they don't have their
accounts signed off and filed in six
months the shares are suspended and that
happens very very occasionally so this
the same big firms that seem Inc capable
of auditing local authorities are quite
clearly able to audit companies and take
take the money and I mean most of these
big firm Partners take a million quid a
year and stuff I think it's quite
appalling really that they got to this
stage
really
no further
questions one other OBS observation that
that comes to mind really very limited
but a bit more reassurance for members
and the public um our various Council
owned companies um have got up todate um
audits external audits uh in place and
signed off um which um is well Al or
they would be in trouble with company's
house
yes I think we're just all feeling we
don't want anything to go seriously
wrong on our watch so um we will keep
pushing them pressurizing okay that's
just um for noting isn't it yeah yeah we
don't need a vote on that um forward
plan last but one item
23 15 um and that she was presenting
that no just no just just for just for
looking at and noting are you happy with
it oh yeah was sorry yeah there was that
one point we wanted to make that the um
the minutes of the last meeting um the
said that the um the committee would
like to see the um the environmental
social governance um matter brought back
to the next meeting um which is today um
but dis discussion with with um the
director and and um Cabinet member um
suggested very very clearly that the the
right time to be discussing that would
be with the treasury um management
strategy which is at the January meeting
so I think that's um just to reassure
ourselves that that's um that is coming
forward Ward um at the next
meeting right thank you so we're all
happy with the forward
plan um that just leaves us to to note
and agree the um confidential minutes
now if we can just do it um on a show of
hands if you want to talk about it we
have to go into part two but I
understand that you're happy with what
was I wasn't here so I can't comment um
enlarge myself but it looks perfect to
me so if we can agree that then um I'll
be happy with
that you yes somebody ought to other
than me yes yeah John to propose um and
um Council register Tim to Second so can
we we need a vote on that do we Bethany
y just give us a minute and it'll be
there I'm
sure thank you chair that vot is now in
progress
e
thank you chair that is seven votes for
and one abstentions that's
carried and for your diligence and
counselors um have a good Christmas and
a great New Year see you in
January